you wrote Life is largely a journey to
discover one's nature and to find parts
that suit one's nature which strikes me
as a really deep truth can you talk
about this importance of the first step
really of self-discovery of figuring out
your own nature and then finding pods
that actually suit your nature right we
are born with nature a certain nature
and that our environments give us a
certain preferences a certain
personality things that we want
and I've seen that through running my
company and that's also why I created
this principles you test that is
available to everybody free so it's like
a half hour a test you answer questions
and everybody virtually said ah that
describes me and it also shows if you
put another person in it it describes
what your relationship with that person
is likely to be like based on what
you're like what your preferences are so
to know your nature
and then you want to match it up with
the path so that you say Ah that's going
to be you know a great path for me